[موسيقى]
يتسم هاتف جلاكسي اس 8 بجوانبه الجذابه
قامت الشركه بتغيير ثلاثه امور لمنح مساحه
اكبر لشاشه الجهاز الزر الرئيسي اصبح
رقميا كما ان زر البصمه وشعار الشركه
انتقل الى الخلف انتقلت الشركه الى
استخدام مدخل يو اس بي سي عوضا عن مداخل
مايكرو يو اس بي وهناك هك وصله تحويل تاتي
مع الجهاز لمن يرغب باستخدام وصلات
الاجهزه السابقه المشكله تمثلت بالوصول
الى زر بصمه الاصبع بالخلف موقع الزر الى
جانب عدسه الكاميرا كان محيرا واضطررنا
الى امساك الهاتف بكلت اليدين للتاكد من
ضغطنا على الزر المناسب الاداء تميز هاتف
جلاكسي اس 8 بسرعه الاستجابه سعه الذاكره
العشوائيه تبلغ 4 جيجا بايت اما سعه
التخزين فتبلغ 64 جيجا بايت ويمكنكم اضافه
المزيد من الذاكره بشريحه مايكرو اس دي
لكن بذلك لن تتمكنوا من استخدام شريحه
ثانيه ان اردتم استخدام خطي هاتف بالجهاز
ذاته اضافت الشركه ماسحا لقزحية
اضعف من قوته بالاضافه الى وجود سماعه
خارجيه واحده في اسفل الجهاز ما ادى الى
عزل الصوت عند استخدام الجهاز في بعض
الاحيان الكاميرا الكاميرا الاماميه تاتي
بوضوح 8 ميجا بكسل وما يميزها وجود خاصيه
سمارت اوتو فوكس للتخلص من التشتيت
بالصوره ينظر وجود هذه الخاصيه بكاميرا
الهواتف الاماميه اما قوه الكاميرا
الخلفيه فتبلغ 12 ميجا بكسل ويمكن
للكاميرا التقاط مقاطع الفيديو بدرجه وضو
2 كي وهذا خبر صار لاصحاب مدونات الفيديو
اختبار
التمساح التصوير بالكاميرا الاماميه
والخلفيه كان جيدا ولم تفقد الصوره
الكثيره من جودتها في الاضواء الخافته
الشاشه حجم الشاشه يبلغ 5.8 انشات بهاتف
جلاكسي اس 8 و6.2 انشات لهاتف اس 8 بلس
الشركه قدمت تصميما مميزا للشاشه بنسبه
العرض للارتفاع في الصوره والتي بلغت 18.5
باي 9
الشاشه مصنعه بتقنيه امولد التي تبرز
الالوان ووجود تقنيه اش دي ار بالشاشه
ساهم بتوفير تجربه مميزه عند مشاهده
الفيديوهات بالاخص مع التطبيقات التي تدعم
الفيديو بوضوح عالي الجوده مثل يوتيوب
ونتفليكس شكرا لمتابعتكم هذا الفيديو
شاهدوا المزيد من هذه الفيديوهات عبر صفحه
تك مع بلس بموقعنا
.c.com